this is a bit of a jarring statistic
Centers for Disease Control says one in
36 children are on the autism spectrum
but now a local school is boosting its
resources to try and help kids and their
parents it's called accelerated Learning
Academy over in the southwest Valley
Lauren Negrete looks at the program and
its impact
since opening in 2021 the academy has
been a One-Stop shop for both education
and therapy I spoke to Founders and to
parents who've seen great improvements
in their kids can you say hi hey a
simple word Keith McIntyre wasn't sure
he'd ever hear from his seven-year-old
son Keith Jr mostly noises up until
around January when he started here like
they taught him see you later they
taught they taught him peace help they
they're the ones that have been helping
him speak it's just been amazing the
McIntyre's struggled to find the right
school for him now at the Academy little
Keith who they call Geeks even plays
like never before
they come up with programs and plans for
us to implement at home so they're not
just teaching him they're teaching us
how to teach him the academy CEO Gwen
Johnson so we wanted to create an
environment where everybody could get
all of their services Under One Roof so
we have applied Behavior Analysis which
is the ABA therapy and we also have
Educational Services Johnson says their
clinical staff works with teachers the
school welcomes kindergarten through
fifth graders with small classes less
than 10 kids to each teacher tuition is
around eighteen thousand dollars a year
they're fundraising for scholarships the
school is in the process of getting
accreditation which parents like Crystal
Garcia are looking forward to so before
accelerated learning he was very shy he
would not socialize with other kids did
not use his words like this and as soon
as we started coming here in January he
opened up like a flower me